Bernie Sanders is beginning his remarks
now Burlington promos what the number of
fatalities may end up being the number
of people who may get ill and we all
hope that that number will be as low as
possible but we also have to face the
truth and that is that the number of
casualties
may actually be even higher and what the
Armed Forces experienced in World War
children in other words we have a major
major crisis and we must act accordingly
therefore it is a absolute moral
imperative that our response as a
government as a society as a business
community and as individual citizens
meet the enormity of this crisis as
people stay or work from home and are
directed to quarantine it will be easy
for us to feel like we are all alone I'm
working at home not at my office or that
we must only worry about ourselves and
think that everybody else should defend
for themselves but in my view that would
be a tragic and dangerous mistake if
that ever was a big time in the modern
history of our country when we are all
in this together
this is that moment now is the time for
solidarity now is the time to come
together with love and compassion for
all including the most vulnerable people
in our society who will face this
endemic from a health perspective will
paste a face it from an economic
perspective if our neighbor
we get sick we have the potential to
become safe if our neighbor loses his or
her job then how the local community
suffers and we may lose our jobs we are
in this together if doctors and nurses
and medical personnel do not have the
equipment and the training and the
capacity they need right now people we
know they are necessarily face
additional illness and even death
we are hold in this together
unfortunately in this time of
international crisis it is clear to me
at least that we have an administration
that is largely incompetent and whose
incompetence and recklessness have
threatened the lives of many many people
in our country so today I would like to
give a brief overview of what in my view
we must do to respond to this crisis
first and foremost we are dealing with a
national emergency and the President of
the United States must understand that
and declare that emergency next because
President Trump is unwilling an elite
unable to lead selflessly we must
immediately convene an emergency
bipartisan authority of experts to
support and direct a response that is
comprehensive compassionate and based
first and foremost on science and fact
in other words Congress in a bipartisan
manner must take responsibility for
addressing this unparalleled crisis
further we must aggressively make serve
that the public sector and the private
sector are strongly cooperating with
each other and we need national and
state hotlines staffed with well trained
people who have the best information
available one of the aspects of the
current crisis is there are people who
are asking them says what are the
symptoms of coronavirus - I have a cold
do I have the flu do I have the car
buyers whose can out me where do I go to
seek medical treatment how do I get a
test when is that test going to be
processed people have a lot of questions
and at the statewide and federal level
we need experts to provide the necessary
information to other people the American
people deserve transparency something
that the current administration has
fought day after day to stifle in other
words we need to know what is happening
right now in our country in our States
and in fact all over the world if there
was ever a time for transparency and
honesty and being straightforward this
is that moment and we need that
information coming from credible
respected scientific voices of which we
have many in our own country and all
over this world not from politicians and
during a crisis we must make sure that
we have for the communities most
vulnerable to the health and economic
pain that is coming those in nursing
homes and rehabilitation facilities
those can find an immigration detention
sentence those who are currently
incarcerated and in jails and all people
regardless of their immigration status
unfortunately as I think the American
people increasingly understand
our country is at a severe disadvantage
compared to every other major country on
earth because we do not guarantee health
care to all people as a right and as we
speak some 87 million Americans are
either uninsured or underinsured and
when you are uninsured or underinsured
you hesitate about getting the medical
care you need because you cannot afford
to get that medical care the result is
that millions of our people cannot
afford to go to a doctor let alone pay
for a coronavirus test so while we work
to pass a medicare-for-all single-payer
system the United States government
today must make it clear that in the
midst of this emergency everyone in our
country regardless of income where they
live must be able to get all of the
health care they need without cost
obviously when a vaccine or other
effective treatment is developed it must
be free of charge we cannot live in a
nation where if you have the money you
get it the treat that you need to
survive but if your working class or
poor you get to the end of the line that
would more be morally unacceptable
further we need emergency funding right
now for paid family and medical leave
anyone who is sick should be able to
stay home during this emergency and
receive their paycheck
what we do not want to see it's at a
time when half of our people are living
paycheck to paycheck when they need to
go to work
order to take care of that family we do
not want to see people going to work who
was sick and who can spread the corona
virus we also need an immediate
expansion of community health centers in
this country so that every American will
have access to a nearby health care
facility where do I go how do I get a
test how do I get the results of that
test need greatly to expand our primary
health care capabilities in this country
and that includes expanding community
health centers we need to determine the
status of our testing and processing for
the corona virus the government must
respond aggressively to make certain
that we in fact have the latest and most
effective tests available and the
quickest means of processing those tests
there are other countries around the
world who are doing better than we are
in that regard we should be learning
from them no one none of the medical
experts that I have talked to dispute
that there is a major shortage of ICU
Yunis and ventilators that are needed to
respond to this crisis the federal
government must work aggressively with
the private sector to make sure that
this equipment is available the
hospitals and the rest of the medical
community our current health care system
does not have the doctors and nurses we
currently need we are understaffed
during this crisis we need to mobilize
medical residents retired medical
professionals and other medical
personnel to help us deal with this
crisis we need to make sure the doctors
nurses and
professionals have the instructions and
personal protective equipment that they
need this is not only because we care
about the well-being of medical
professionals but here they don't have
that our capability to respond to this
crisis is significantly diminished the
pharmaceutical industry must be told in
no uncertain terms that the medicines
that they manufacture for this crisis
will be sold at cost this is not the
time for price gouging or profiteering
the corona virus is already causing a
global economic meltdown which is
impacting people throughout the world
and in our own country and it is
especially dangerous for low-income and
working class families people who today
before the crisis are struggling
economically instead of providing more
tax breaks to the top 1% and large
corporations we need to provide economic
assistance to the elderly and I worry
very much of how elderly people in this
country today many of whom are isolated
many of them do not have a lot of money
we need to worry about those who are
already sick we need to worry about
working families with children people
with disabilities the homeless and fold
those who are old we need to provide in
that context emergency unemployment
assistance to anyone in this country who
loses their job through no fault of
their own
right now 23 percent of those who are
eligible to receive unemployment
compensation do not receive it under our
proposal everyone who loses a job must
qualify one
women compensation at least 100 percent
of their prior salary with a cap of
eleven hundred and fifty dollars a week
was $60,000 a year in addition those who
depend on tips and the restaurant
industry is suffering very much from the
meltdown those who depend on tips gig
workers
domestic workers and independent
contractors must also qualify for
unemployment insurance to make up for
the income that they lose during this
crisis we need to make sure that the
elderly people with disabilities and
families with children have access to
nutritious food that means expanding the
meals-on-wheels program it means
expanding the school lunch program and
snap so that no one goes hungry during
this crisis and everyone who cannot
leave their home can receive nutritious
meals to live it directly to where they
live we need also in this economic
crisis to place an immediate moratorium
on evictions on foreclosures and on
utility shops so that no one loses their
home during this crisis and that
everyone has access to clean water
electricity heat and air conditioning we
need to control emergency homeless
shelters to make sure that the homeless
survivors of domestic violence and
college students quarantine while campus
are able to receive the shelter the
health care and the nutrition they need
we need to provide emergency lending to
small and medium sized businesses to
come a payroll new construction of
manufacturing facilities and production
of emergency supplies such as masks and
ventilators a very serious problem right
now
the midst of this crisis here is the
bottom line and that bottom line is that
in the midst of this unprecedented
moment we need to listen to the
scientists to the researchers to the
medical folks not the politicians we
need an emergency response to the
current emergency and we need it
immediately we need more doctors and
nurses in underserved areas we need to
make sure the doctor that workers who
lose their jobs in this crisis perceive
the unemployment assistance they need
and in this moment in this moment we
need to make sure that in the future
after this crisis is behind us we build
a healthcare system that makes sure that
every person in this country is
guaranteed that healthcare